hey guys it is Monday the eighth of
December today my name is Jess McDonald
and you're watching gamespot news some
destiny players are having trouble
getting into the game ever since a bug
who spawned from pre-ordering the dark
below dlc a number of gamers have taken
to the internets to say that purchasing
the deals see presented them with a
countdown timer for its release which
they are unable to bypass to get into
the base game currently the issue only
seems to be affecting users who grabbed
a digital version of the game on ps4 and
then attempted to buy the dlc standalone
hopefully the problem will at least
resolve itself by the time the DLC is
officially out tomorrow but this is
probably the worst pre-order incentive
we've ever seen The Witcher 3 has been
delayed yet again much to our dismay
originally jus in February of 2015 the
hotly-anticipated action RPG is now set
to land months later on May nineteen
develop a CD Projekt RED released a
statement explaining the sheer size and
complexity of the witcher key features
of the title have had a decisive impact
on production now nearing the end of our
work we see many details that need to be
corrected in march studio co-founder
marsena vince key promised there would
be no further delays but the devas
explained that it just hasn't worked out
that way you can check out the full open
letter from the depth to which our fans
on gamespot over the weekend we found
out street fighter 5 is coming but it's
going to be exclusive to pc and ps4
microsoft exec phil spencer has
commented on the announcement claiming
that xbox simply can't win all business
deals well he did say that xbox will
make exclusivity deals he also stated
the importance of Microsoft owning IP
explaining there is a mix of deals to do
but making sure we own IP that xbox
gamers love is critical in my opinion
I'd love it if xbox fans could play all
the games but business jumps make some
deal happen it's all part of petition
ask you a question of the day let me
know if you're a fan of exclusives or if
you'd like your games available on every
platform if you're often one year's you
can head to gain swap for stories on a
holographic Paul McCartney and yet
another Assassin's Creed unity patch
that is it for me today I have a bunch
more news for you same time tomorrow so
i hope you then